ils ont entre 25 et 45 ans et depuis des
mois ils occupent les bureaux de la
municipalité cette semaine de
contestation en évoque d'autres un peu
partout en tunisie c'est le chômage et
la pauvreté qui les unissent tous sont
diplômés aucun n'a trouvé de travail
hamel a obtenu un diplôme en travail
social il ya cinq ans mais elle n'a
jamais trouvé de poste
windisch riche neige je n'ai rien pour
me permettre de vivre seul dieu m'aide
je vis dans une situation sociale très
difficile je suis orpheline de mère et
mon père ne travaille pas notre
situation est lamentable à vrai dire
squatter les bureaux de l'administration
locale c'est tout ce qu'elle et ses
compagnons d'infortuné peuvent faire
pour se rappeler à la mémoire d'un
gouvernement qui les ignorent distille
conserver tous nous avons le droit de
travailler c'est un droit garanti dans
la constitution tunisienne à l'article
12 qui toucherait les dix que nous avons
le droit à l'emploi
mais le gouvernement n'a aucune solution
pour nous même match
on nous accuse d'empêcher la liberté de
travail je ne sais pas de quel travail
on part qu'il n'y a aucune production
aucune richesse aucune administration
rien sadek à 29 ans il est l'instigateur
de cette occupation
comme beaucoup de tunisiens lui qui a
été très actif pour renverser la
dictature de benali regrette aujourd'hui
non pas sans amertume
cette époque nous ne méritons pas la clé
m nous avons gagné la liberté la parole
mais nous n'avons encore rien gagné côté
économique et social en effet on n'a
rien n'allait benali était plus
miséricordieux la limougeaude au moins
le lait le sucre et les produits de base
était disponible
sauf qu'un mode lasemo jaune le 17
décembre 2010 mohamed bouazizi s'immole
est à sidi bouzid une ville du centre du
pays
il en mourra une dizaine de jours plus
tard la mort atroce d'une jeune sans
emploi qui survivaient en vendant noire
des fruits et légumes a provoqué
l'étincelle qui allait embraser toute
l'afrique du nord le 14 janvier 2011
benali fuyaient la tunisie la transition
démocratique est aujourd'hui malmenée
par une profonde crise économique
inflation chute abrupte du dinar chômage
endémique
tous ces indicateurs affolant de la
situation économique provoque chez de
plus en plus de tunisiens un mépris de
la classe politique que l'on qualifie
dans les conversations de corrompu
criminel voire même de terroristes dont
100 parfois s'attirer des ennuis avec la
justice
si le système ne coûte pas c'est le
système et il ne réagit pas vous désirez
house et après vous attaque avec leurs
matraques avec leurs policiers et l'os
avec leurs outils
alors c'est une guerre si le c'est un
petit côté il reste avec vous et
trouvent des solutions et ça ça c'est
une états s'est il fait tout ce qu'il
veut et
mais le peuple à la halle en faire le le
peuvent à faire vivre l'enfer en
septembre dernier l'activiste s'est
présenté à l'entrée de la casbah où
parlement tunis avec l'intention de se
sacrifier
puis aussi pour lancer un message un
gouvernement qui l'accuse d'anéantir
tous les espoirs unis d'une révolution
qui va détourner
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont été
brûlés en tunisie beaucoup la suicide en
tunisie en augmentation sipa le je suis
pas le premier ni le dernier en tunisie
ça suscitait le tunisien j'ai dit du
livre soit un terroriste soit suicide
sur la messagerie sol le nas vallée le
fanfaron
[Musique]
abdelrazzaq gorgui caméraman photographe
et père de famille de 32 ans enregistré
ce message dénonçant la pauvreté la
précarité qui sont le lot d'une majorité
de la jeunesse tunisienne
quelques minutes avant de se donner la
mort sa mort atroce a bien provoqué des
manifestations mais de courte durée
elles ont été réprimées par les forces
de l'ordre le calme est de retour place
des martyrs à kaffrine aujourd'hui mais
la colère sourde grande toujours alors
qu'on trompe l'ennui et un profond
mal-être sur les bancs publics à
quelques kilomètres de là les occupants
des bureaux de magella la baisse se
reconnaissent dans toute cette douleur
un rapide sondage du groupe de
contestataires révèle que la majorité
des chômeurs ici a aussi fait des
tentatives de suicide et vie moi ou la
lie à lubumbashi
ah oui c'était ma première tentative et
je vais réessayer parc en réalité la
situation que nous vivons est très
difficile c'est un abattage soient
maîtres humains je ressens une tristesse
profonde je ne peux rien dire de plus
vraiment menteur
gould elle et ses camarades sont
désormais libres de dire tous leurs
malles et leur désespoir
mais à quoi bon s'exprime et se
demandent s'il si personne ne veut
entendre ici marie-eve bédard radio
canada en tunisie